ist ein preisschock den deutschland
gerade erlebt die sorge von millionen
menschen dass unser alltag einfach nicht
mehr bezahlbar ist und doch gibt es
immer mehr politiker und jetzt auch
journalisten die sich darüber freuen die
sagen genau richtig wenn ihr es euch
nicht mehr leisten können dann
verbraucht halt einfach weniger so zum
beispiel klangs am abend im kommentar
bei den ard tagesthemen
er ist da der preisschock gut so denn
nur wenn öl und gas spürbar teurer
werden kriegen wir die erderwärmung in
den griff mehr windräder und
solarenergie so lange können wir nicht
warten und sollten froh sein dass wir
gezwungen werden konsum und produktion
zu ändern achtsames heizen weniger
energiefresser im haushalt keine
kurzstreckenflüge aber auch zum beispiel
stahl moderne herstellen oder aluminium
und wollten wir das nicht sowieso nur
dass jetzt die märkte das tempo
diktieren und nicht mehr unsere viel zu
zaghaften politik
was wird es noch mal ganz kurz an einem
besonderen mission ziert habe ich damit
sagen an dem kommentar von gestrigen
abend
er ist da der preisschock gut so denn
nur wenn öl und gas spürbar teurer
werden kriegen wir die erderwärmung in
den griff mehr windräder und
solarenergie so lange können wir nicht
warten und sollten froh sein dass wir
gezwungen werden konsum und produktion
zu ändern achtsames heizen weniger
energiefresser im haushalt keine kurt er
ist da der preisschock gut so
da hat der fraktion sind studie nochmal
gekommen ralf schuler chef des bild
parlamentsbüros also erst da der
preisschock und gut so ja ich freue mich
dass ich wir sollten dankbar sein dass
wir gezwungen werden das ist eigentlich
eine etwas seltene haltung einem
politischen betrieb es klingt so ein
bisschen wie politische sadomaso
zwingen mich dass ich besser werde in
einem ernst der preisschock ist
natürlich da das hat verschiedene gründe
einmal lieferengpässe bei chips dann das
opec kartell was weiterhin die preise
für öl und dementsprechend energie
hochhält und wir können von der
zentralbank nicht gegensteuern nur sich
dafür zu bedanken dass jetzt alles teuer
wird das ist schon sehr sehr zynisch
abgehoben gerade für diejenigen die froh
sind wenn sie mit einer schwarzen null
monatsende auf dem girokonto rausgehen
da ist es mir darüber sprechen wie eng
es für viele wird und wen das vor allem
alles betrifft also ganz konkret was
wird teurer und wem tut der verein
besonders wegen der erzeuger wir haben
schon angesprochen energie ist vor allem
betroffen also benzin haben wir gerade
große rückstände für alle pendler ist
das natürlich eine schwierige geschichte
erfahrungsgemäß wird die
pendlerpauschale dann irgendwann
angehoben aber sehr viel später auch
erst ab 22 kilometer ist kann einfach
nicht jeder ausreichend auf öffentliche
dann haben wir eine ganze reihe von
consumer produkten wieder sind der
bahnen sprache so schön heißt also
unterhaltungselektronik küchen
elektronik und ähnliches das ist jetzt
nicht zwingend dass man sich permanent
neue sachen kaufen muss aber hin und
wieder muss es manchmal sein und wenn
eine waschmaschine kaputt ist oder ein
kühlschrank muss man es halt auch
ersetzen und das andere sind halt eben
auch lebensmittel weil auch dort die
ressourcen knapp werden und die preise
steigen und wir haben im augenblick ein
informationsfenster von etwa vier
prozent früher hat die europäische
zentralbank 2 prozent als ziel angepeilt
und so schnell mit tariferhöhungen nach
führen kann würde ich auch nicht ja und
entlastung auch erstmal nicht hinaus
sich schon gar nicht eine regierung
gehen aussicht die sich um diese
probleme aktuell kümmern das ganze
inflation richtung 5 prozent und vor
allen dingen merken was ja beim
spritpreis so krass im moment
mittlerweile an einigen tankstellen der
liter benzin schon über zwei liter und
gerade haben das im tagesthemen
kommentar schon gesehen es gibt immer
mehr die sagen ist doch gut so ist doch
genau das was wir wollten und auch die
spd-politikerin früher justizministerin
katharina bali heute in europa unterwegs
hat diesen satz bei den kollegen von
hart aber fair bei frank plasberg gesagt
die kilowattstunde die am besten ist es
die die man nicht verbraucht aber wenn
man zum beispiel sich neue fenster hat
einbauen lassen oder gedämmt hat also
jetzt nicht einfach wird alles gefördert
genau also weniger verbraucht dann kommt
man voll in den genuss dann kann man
sogar sagen hey jeder stunde die jetzt
habe ich mehr gespart also das ist die
haltung von vielen politikern aktuell
design genau das wollten wir doch und
jetzt wenn es ein problem ist dass ihr
sollt nicht leisten können greift dann
verbraucht doch einfach wenig absolut
und wenn es kein brot gibt kann man
kuchen essen also die sozialdemokratie
an der seite zu haben da hat man aber
echten fund ist meinte das spricht
wirklich eine blinde von der farbe wenn
man sich fenster einbauen lässt dann
zahlt man im 10.000 euro bereich wenn
einem das haus denn selbst gehört als
mieter kann man es ja nicht und man hat
bei aller förderung natürlich trotzdem
immer noch einen gewaltigen brocken den
man zahlen muss die idee dahinter man
kauft sich effizientere geräte mit denen
spart man dann so viel dass man die
preissteigerung wieder auffängt die
funktioniert ja nicht das hat schon die
mineralölsteuer gezeigt dass hat die
ökosteuer gezeigt immer die idee ich
kaufe mir einen kühlschrank mit der
klasse a+++ der würde dann so viel
sparen dass ich den mehrpreis und die
steigenden energiepreise wieder
reinkriegen der funktioniert in der
praxis nicht weil die ersparen ist
einfach viel zu gering ist im vergleich
zu dem was die energiepreise klettern
als könnte die politik denn ganz konkret
tun um die zu entlasten die es am
dringendsten brauchen also rentnerinnen
und rentner pendler geringverdiener gibt
es da vorschläge also man kann natürlich
den mindestlohn erhöhen man kann auch
nicht politisch erhöhen sondern man der
wird ohnehin angepasst bleibt trotzdem
auf dem untersten level wenn man kann
die geringfügigkeitsgrenze anheben man
kann steuerfreibeträge setzen und bei
den renten gibt es natürlich im
kommenden jahr ohnehin auch einen
automatischen ausgleich also das
absacken der renten ist nach unten hin
gedeckelt unten nach oben können rentner
was drauf das sind also die gruppen die
am wenigsten davon betroffen sind auch
wenn die zeit bis dahin natürlich noch
länger ist schwieriger ist es bei
normalen erwerbstätigen die müssten über
tarifabschlüsse mehr geld fordern das
ist so schnell nicht zu machen auch bei
länger laufenden tarifabschlüssen ist
das schwierig und ansonsten hat die
politik einfach das problem dass wenn
sie abgaben senkt um preise zu drücken
das dann meistens die unternehmen ganz
schnell mit ihren preisen hoch gehen und
das ausgleichen so dass man nicht
wirklich eine ersparnis hat aber die
politik scheint seltsam entspannt noch
zu sehr in angesichts der ängste
angesichts der sorgen von millionen
deutschen dass der alltag eben nicht
mehr bezahlbar ist der spd chef norbert
walter borjans hat aktuell das hier
gesagt zur inflationsangst in
deutschland erhält diese angst offenbar
überhaupt nicht für berechtigt er sagt
aktuell dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland dass wir deutsche uns
angesichts unserer geschichte besondere
sorgen um inflation machen das ist
verständlich aktuell begründet sind
diese sorgen nicht sagt norbert walter
borjans also
irgendwie falsch oder
193 inflation aber
gut das ist jetzt auch mal wieder
sozialdemokratischer empathie pur
er erklärt dass sozusagen zu einer
historischen marotte mit blick auf die
zwanzigerjahre oma und opa hatten damals
noch ihre sparstrümpfe und über nacht
waren das war das nur noch wenige wert
aber ganz so einfach ist es natürlich
nicht das bittere daran ist wenn man
sich jetzt die koalitionsverhandlungen
anguckt da gibt es große einigkeit in
der freigabe von cannabis das ist sehr
schön aber die wirklichen
alltagsprobleme die wirklich millionen
betreffen die sind da einfach nicht im
blick und solche äußerungen kommen
natürlich bei frau bali genauso wie bei
hans von leuten die die fahrbereitschaft
des bundestages in anspruch nehmen
können die ihre pensionen nach langen
politischen leben völlig korrekt legal
und und zu recht gesichert haben und da
auch dann anpassungen bekommen wenn die
preise steigen das ist aber geradezu
zynisch wenn man das den kleinen leuten
auf der straße erzählt wir wollen
darüber gleich aussprechen mit dem noch
bundesverkehrsminister andreas scheuer
der ja kurz vor der wahl angekündigt hat
die spritpreis bremse zu treten wenn der
spritpreis über die zweiliter rüber
rutscht jetzt haben wir es an einigen
tankstellen schon mal gucken was er
gleich hier sagen wird bleibt nicht mal
vorher wollen wir noch einmal hören was
sie auf der straße aktuell sagen zur
eigenen inflationsangst und zu
offenbaren schulterzucken der politik
aktuell unser kollege michael engelberg
hat sich umgehört bochum
[Musik]
die verarschen uns erstens den kleinen
mann
und sie sehen zudem eine voll wird die
kosten explodieren und es wird einfach
nichts gemacht auf der anderen seite
werden atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet
obwohl die erneuerbaren energien hat
überhaupt nicht in dem gleichen maße
ausgebaut werden und wir importieren
immer mehr energie die wir dann teuer
bezahlen müssen und das merke ich am
ende auch in meinem portemonnaie ja was
ich im moment abspielt aber man weiß
nicht was zu tun ist sagen mal so das
einzigste was passiert ist die kosten
sind in den letzten jahren um 200
prozent gestiegen
dann will man ersparen da muss man immer
nur drauf legen jetzt habe ich hier ein
paar blümchen da da bin ich zehn
fünfzehn euro los das ist wahnsinn was
da im moment passiert
ist das auch bei diesen produkten
gestiegen ja was ich im korb ab ja das
also äpfel kosten ab 50 cent wenn man
das umrechnet ist was eine marke hunde
anna ist
sie also so geht es ihnen dort sind
menschen zb in bochum mit diesem
preisschock alles wird teurer alles ist
bereits schon teurer und es droht uns
auch noch ein winter wo alles noch
teurer wird und die politik schaut
derzeit einfach dabei zu
[Musik]